ma question s'adresse au premier flic de
France à ce jour pas moins de 17
enquêtes ont été ouvertes à l'IGPN sans
compter les arrestations préventives les
coups de matraques reçus par des
manifestants et parfois par de simples
passants par vos voltigeurs deux
personnes sont dans le coma depuis ce
weekend des jeunes femmes ont été
victimes d'agression sexuelle à Nantes
des milliers de grenades de
désencerclement de gaz lacrymo était
lancés à l'aveugle bref l'escalade ces
violences elles sont aujourd'hui
documentées filmées visibles on ne peut
pas continuer de les ignorer il semble
que vous cherchiez à attiser les
tensions afin d'incarner l'ordre et de
sortir de cette crise par le recours à
l'autorité vous instrumentalisez ainsi
les agents de police alors vous devez en
sortir par la raison c'est à dire par le
retrait de la réforme des retraites par
ce geste d'apaisement demandé par
l'intersyndicale alors Monsieur Darmanin
quand allez-vous arrêter d'être le
premier flic de France pour devenir
ministre de l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire au
service de l'intérêt général et de la
démocratie
de France parce que je n'ai pas le
courage ni vous d'ailleurs d'être à la
place des policiers qui chaque jour
risque leur vie pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
confonde casseurs et policiers que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on n'est
pas un mot dans une question d'actualité
pour penser à tous ces policiers ces
gendarmes qui sont blessés que s'est-il
passé à gauche quand on a pas un mot
quand on attaque des commissariats des
tribunaux des préfectures des
permanences de parlementaires que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
confonds manifestation interdite et
manifestations autorisées que s'est-il
passé à gauche pour qu'on ne respecte
plus l'uniforme de la République que
s'est-il passé à gauche madame la
députée pour qu'on oublie à ce point
Clémenceau Chevènement Cazeneuve Valls
Mitterrand Badinter
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
aisse des policiers que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour faire alliance avec Monsieur
Mélenchon qui les insultent qu'il est
vomit et qui finalement fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche je n'ai
insulté personne monsieur le ministre
aux policiers et aux gendarmes que vous
blessez chaque jour vous devriez
présenter vos excuses à l'uniforme de la
République sur lequel vous crachez et
vous devriez présenter vos excuses
d'attisées par la colère ce que vous
n'avez pas eu par les urnes
[Applaudissements]